[Musique]
depuis deux mois déjà les allemands
n'ont pas le chois masque obligatoire
dans les transports en commun mais aussi
dans les lieux publics dans les magasins
passe mais à la digue service avec
l'assouplissement des restrictions il
faut porter le masque dit la chancelière
les parisiens qui oublient leurs masques
par le métro peuvent perdre beaucoup
d'argent 200 $ et 100 $ si on vous voit
jeter un masque par terre l'italie qui a
été l'épicentre de l'épidémie en europe
n'a pas tardé à agir
depuis début mai transports publics et
magasins n'accepte plus personne avec le
visage découvert
la ville de moscou elle a ajouté les
gants obligatoires dans tous les lieux
fermés et les transports
et comme tous les pays agissent et en
ordre dispersé dablé joe handley
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
mis à jour ses directives début juin et
s'appuie sur une étude canadienne
publiée dans de l'inde 7 qui conclut que
les masques peuvent réduire le risque
d'infection de 85%
elle recommande l'usagé du masque même
nom médical
même si la liste des inconvénients et
plus longue que celle des avantages
selon le ms contribuer à stopper le
virus d'un côté risque d'auto
contamination de l'autre infections
réduite mais problème de maux de tête
voire de lésions cutanées
aux etats unis le masque est vu par
certains comme une attaque à la liberté
individuelle quand il est obligatoire
comme à new york ou los angeles ainsi
que dans une quarantaine
tu as et une partie de la population
refuse par principe de le porter autant
de problèmes qui n'en sont plus depuis
plus de 15 ans dans les pays touchés par
le strass en 2003 en chine mais aussi à
taiwan en corée du sud ou encore à hong
kong
le masque est automatique dès qu'un
virus circule peut-être qu'il deviendra
désormais un réflexe chez les
occidentaux ici mathieu prost radio
canada montréal